good afternoon I'm Matthew Spalding
associate vice president Dean for
Hillsdale College here in Washington DC
thank you for coming on a busy week both
immediately today and the events here in
town for this important talk by a friend
of ours the college was founded in 1844
to perpetuate through sound learning
civil and religious freedom and
intelligent piety last week we
celebrated Constitution Day one way we
advanced sound learning is we require
each one of our students in our core
curriculum to take course on the United
States Constitution one of the only
colleges in the country to do so but of
course that sound education is something
that's not just for our students but for
all American citizens we do online
courses in which over 1 million
enrollees so far have taken those
courses the core of which is a core
course on the United States Constitution
um one of the important things we teach
in that course is a proper understanding
of the branches of the United States
government the Declaration of
Independence rests the sovereignty and
the people and that power is then
delegated through the Constitution to
three branches of government not just
one each having unique powers delegated
to them the courts should not make law
or execute it but should adjudicate it
it's a policy of the government on final
questions to always turn the court as
Lincoln famously said we have turned
over our rule to that eminent tribunal
so here are three months after two major
Supreme Court decisions in a better
position to assess the meaning of those
decisions what do they tell us about the
courses thinking or lack thereof or
about the courts jurisprudence our
attack thereof do these decisions in
particular the over overt fell decision
present a new and ever more extravagant
conception of just supremacy the quote
that is used or the topic today's
lecture we have a good friend scholar
who's going to discuss this topic he
will be introduced formally by a student
currents to divorce evan Melanson is a
junior from Long Beach California she's
an American Studies major at Hillsdale
and is currently interning with the
United States Capitol
society and on pills campus she is a
resident assistant and member of Pi Beta
Phi sorority Thank You dr. Spaulding
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen and
welcome Matthew Frank is director of the
William II and Carol G Simon Simon
Center on religion and the Constitution
at Witherspoon Institute he is a
professor emeritus at Radford University
where he taught constitutional law
American politics and political
philosophy and a visitor lecturer in
politics at Princeton University dr.
Frank is the author of against and
against the imperial dirt Judah Carrie
be it the Supreme Court versus the
sovereignty of the people and the
forthcoming strict scrutiny sense and
nonsense on the Supreme Court he has
written for a numerous numerous
newspapers and journals including the
Washington Post first thing's National
Review and The Claremont Review on books
and as a regular blogger on the NRO's
bench memos page please by me in
welcoming dr. Matthew Frank
thanks very much for that kind welcome
it's a great pleasure to be here at a
bastion of constitutionalism and in a
place that doesn't see much of it
Washington DC my title as as indicated
is an extravagant conception of judicial
supremacy rescuing the Constitution from
the Supreme Court of the 76 cases
decided in the October 2014 term of the
Supreme Court to stood out from its
final week as garnering the most
attention King versus Burwell on the
Obama administration's decision to
extend the Affordable Care Act's
subsidies and mandates to states where
there is a health insurance exchange
created not by the state but by the
federal government and obergefell versus
Hodges in which the court held that the
14th amendment requires States to grant
marriage licenses to same-sex couples
each decision elicited very sharp
dissents in which the justices in the
minority pointedly argued that the
majority had overstepped the proper
boundaries of judicial power but so far
so normal such a charge leveled in a
dissent is actually not all that unusual
in the modern Supreme Court but then
neither is it unusual for the charge to
be a just one in King Justice Scalia in
high dudgeon as only he can be
complained that by reading the ACA as
though exchange created by the state
could also mean exchanges created by the
Secretary of Health and Human Services
the court's opinion by Chief Justice
Roberts quote both the grand eise's
judicial power and encourages
congressional lassitude by making a
choice that should be made by Congress
yet obergefell which I'll talk about
today presents us with an instance of
judicial two grand iseman on a much
grander scale and not just because its
impact on the institution of marriage is
devastating nor because of its fallout
for family for religious liberty or for
the foundations of a free society what I
want to highlight is a peculiar
brazenness about the decision
the sheer boldness of the
pratense that the Constitution
guarantees the right of same-sex
marriage is breathtaking and the
blundering incompetence of Justice
Kennedy's majority opinion which almost
defies analysis because it answers to
known legal norms or categories is
infuriating but there's more her burqa
fell arrived after a struggle of nearly
twenty years duration in which the
defenders of marriage saw it coming and
took active determined indeed
unprecedented steps to prevent it in the
mid-nineteen ninety's state judges in
Hawaii and Alaska first began to flirt
with the idea of imposing same-sex
marriage in their jurisdictions as a
requirement of their state constitutions
this prompted the first wave of state
constitutional amendments in the passage
of the Defense of Marriage Act in
Congress in 1996 an effort to forestall
a domino effect should one or more
states be toppled by their own activist
judges when the first state fell
Massachusetts in 2003 these efforts were
redoubled with a large number of states
amending their constitutions at the
polls the following year same-sex
marriage advocates while heartily
scornful of democratic institutions
wherever they could be persuaded relied
heavily on activist courts because their
cause was in most places unpopular
marriage defenders on the other hand
justifiably mistrustful of legal elites
populating the courts tried to head them
off by democratic means California of
course was the hinge of the struggle
when the state Supreme Court redefined
marriage in 2008 on a pretext that the
California Constitution required it the
people of the state succeeded in just a
few months in passing Proposition 8
undo that decision by amending the
Constitution but the sequel was judge
Vaughn Walker 's Lawless farce of a
trial in district court of prop eights
federal constitutional merits his
preposterous ruling was affirmed by a
panel of the Ninth Circuit which changed
all the reasoning then came the
spectacle of the Supreme Court ruling in
2013 that the citizens who had
successfully amended California's
Constitution had no standing on appeal
to defend their handiwork which oddly
enough left in place judge Walker's
ruling a result that no lawyer in
America has yet adequately explained the
same day is that ruling in Hollingsworth
versus Perry the Supreme Court wrongly
struck down one of the two key
provisions of DOMA in the Windsor case
United States versus Windsor wenzer in
turn was taken as a green light
notwithstanding assurances in the
opinion that it shouldn't be by lower
court judges but they should begin to
follow judge Walker's lead and strike
down state laws protecting marriage as a
union of a man and a woman now the
purpose of this quick tour of probably
familiar history to this audience is to
remind you that over the last two
decades there has been consistent rule
following by the defenders of marriage
informing to democratic and
constitutional norms and just as
consistent rule breaking by state and
later federal judges at the behest of
same-sex marriage advocates violating
one legal and constitutional norm after
another wherever they were unable to
achieve their object democratically
which was most of the country in
addition to Domas passage by Congress in
1996 defenders of marriage managed to
amend the Constitution's of three fifths
of the states to protect marriages true
meaning in the law we may say therefore
that the federal judiciary no less than
the state courts was on notice of what a
clear majority of the American people
believed about marriage and its place in
our legal order yet this availed the
people nothing our judicial elite elites
have been impatient for this social
change culturally the captives of a
classic rent-seeking interest group and
dismissive of constitutional niceties
like the people's right to make the laws
either directly or through their elected
representatives five justices of the
Supreme Court have now attempted to shut
down the democratic process with a lie
about the meaning of the Constitution
for the sake of a lie about the meaning
of marriage in one grimly fascinating
respect then fascinating in the same way
as watching a train wreck in a slow
motion our recent experience culminating
in obergefell is worse than the
experience that resulted in Roe versus
Wade aside from a small number of
interested court watchers that case
stole upon a largely unsuspecting
country in 1973 almost all the furor
over Roe has followed the ruling over
the last 42 years and it is fair to say
that the justices who decided it
probably had no idea of the firestorm
they were touching off not so this time
the justices who decided obergefell this
June at two decades notice that the
American people were really paying
attention to this issue but they really
care about it and are seriously divided
about it and that many clearly foresaw
dreaded and used their legitimate
Democratic power to head off what
eventually came to pass now whether the
five justices who made up the bare
majority in the case get away with it is
entirely up to us but just as
unprecedented as the majority's brazen
usurpation committed in bold defiance of
twenty years worth of warnings is the
call to arms for the American people to
resist the decision issued by home by
the four dissenters in obergefell in my
thirty years of studying writing about
and teaching the subject of
constitutional jurisprudence I have
never read anything like those four
dissents with the possible exception of
the two dissents in the Dred Scott case
of 1857 the dissenters in obergefell
directly attack not just the reasoning
or result but the legitimacy of the
majority's decision this should be
considered as inviting their fellow
citizens to resist it the Chief Justice
sets the tone writing that the justices
and the majority have engaged in in his
words an act of will not of legal
judgment stealing the issue from the
his words again he asks just who do we
think we are it's a very good question
there's much more in this vein in the
Chiefs opinion which should be widely
read but I want to notice something else
more subtle that he does it's customary
for dissenters not to refer to the
author of the majority opinion by name
but instead to refer to what the court
says in its opinion this is actually to
show respect by treating the author of
the majority as speaking in the Court's
own institutional voice used to the
expression the court may be alternated
with the majority just to relieve the
monotony but in the typical case nothing
more is meant by the two expressions the
majority and the court yet in obergefell
there's a marked imbalance in the use of
these expressions Roberts refers only
seven or eight times to the justices in
the majority as the court and he always
does so when speaking of what they've
done they've stopped the debate they've
been validated the law they've done this
they've done that when he describes what
they say the reasoning in the published
opinion of the court Roberts
consistently says that the majority says
this or that thing he does this 66 times
in a dissent of 29 pages this is in
itself a clear indication that for
Roberts the opinion of the majority is
simply not to be dignified with the
Honorable title opinion of the court it
lacks the constitutional legitimacy such
a description would indicate this well
the dissenters follow suit like Roberts
the other three dissenters who all wrote
their own individual opinions usually
joined by one another like Roberts they
prefer the majority when referring to
the reasons and arguments offered in
that opinion they do this about 40 times
collectively in their combined 35 pages
compared to a roughly 10 times mostly in
Scalia's opinion actually that they
refer to the court it's as though the
four dissenters had agreement agreed
among themselves beforehand or while
drafting to refrain as much as possible
from the usual references to the court
saying this or that thing in order to
indicate their shared view that the
ruling is not the legitimate law of the
land as a pronouncement of the court
what is the mere opinion of phrase they
use very many times a bare majority of
phrase appears more than once five
unelected lawyers it's their way of
saying that this is not law but raw
politics now I actually want to focus
more closely on something else
the chief says in his eloquent dissent
when he writes this nowhere is the
majority's extravagant conception of
judicial supremacy more evident and it's
in its description and dismissal of the
public debate regarding same-sex
marriage now we're in striking distance
of the greatest constitutional problem
we face today the problem of judicial
supremacy many people use this phrase
and know it describes a problem but I
want to try and achieve some clarity on
the problem I wonder if for instance
what Chief Justice Roberts himself means
by judicial supremacy I can think of
three possible meanings for the phrase
and for the Hillsdale students in the
room there will be a quiz at the end
first the supreme authority of the
federal judiciary to decide any
important political or social question
confronting the country whether the
Constitution authentically addresses it
or not but the judges will of course say
that it does second the power of the
federal judiciary to interpret any and
all textual provisions or principles of
the Constitution so long as bare
jurisdictional and standing requirements
are met by parties who bring a case to
the courts third a decisive right to be
obeyed that is the authority of the
federal judiciary to impose an
obligation of obedience to its
interpretations of the Constitution
equivalent to
sworn obligation all office holders have
to conform their actions to the
Constitution itself I think that the
chief actually only means the first of
these for him it will be the most
alarming I think I call it the first one
the judicial supremacy of imperial power
the the the background thinking goes
something like this we justices yet to
impose our moral vision on the country
because insulated as as we are from
politics we are able to use the
Constitution's majestic generalities to
achieve policy outcomes that are
substantively just for contemporary
needs founded on principle and not on
the grubby jostling of interests that
characterizes ordinary politics now John
Roberts who famously described the
Supreme Court as an umpire calling balls
and strikes and who really meant that
can be expected to recoil from this
understanding of the judicial role and
his dissent in obergefell is an
impassioned denunciation of it but
consider now the second meaning of the
phrase which I'll call the judicial
supremacy of textual breath in this
understanding we stay inside the four
corners of the Constitution's text but
we gather into the courts purview
everything we find there all the
Constitution's principles and provisions
are potentially the material from which
a judicial decision can be formed this
may sound uncomfort
but for much of our history this was not
the court's own view of things even in
Marbury vs. Madison the case famous from
1803 for declaring a part of a federal
law unconstitutional in thus being the
first exercise of federal judicial
review even in Marbury there was a
companion doctrine that came to be
called the doctrine of political
questions these two judicial review and
the doctrine of political questions
comfortably coexisted for many years the
one saying that judges in appropriate
cases can decide which acts of other
institutions are constitutional and the
other saying but not every
constitutional question gives rise to
such appropriate cases and so some
issues real constitutional issues the
judges simply won't decide in the last
last half-century however in a judgment
that is pardon me in the development
that has not been given nearly enough
attention the doctrine of political
questions is all but vanished from
constitutional law nowadays it is fair
to say that the Supreme Court generally
considers the whole Constitution in all
its parts as within its own power to
enforce against all comers and in
response to every species of complaint
it can be framed by a lawyer in the
familiar vocabulary of the law perhaps
the most troubling of the possible
meanings of judicial supremacy is the
third one which I'll call the judicial
supremacy of authoritative depth so we
have bred and now we have depth this is
the view that when the Supreme Court has
announced in a case an interpretation of
the Constitution's meaning that
effectively is the Constitution's
meaning for the rest of us this means in
a remark attributed the Charles Evans
Hughes before he became Chief Justice
that quote we are under a Constitution
but the Constitution is what the judges
say it is and all other citizens but
particularly those who serve in public
office federal or state are obliged to
conform their
as to what the Supreme Court justices or
at least five of them tell them the
Constitution means since all public
officials in the u.s. taken oath of
office in which they swear to uphold the
Constitution the judicial supremacy of
authoritative depth can be taken to mean
that actually all public officials take
an oath to uphold whatever the Supreme
Court may say the Constitution is the
justices of the court on the other hand
are not even oath bound to follow their
own precedence but may have returned
them if they disagree with them that is
the court is always right except when
five of the current justices decide it
has been wrong it follows that the
Supreme Court is a kind of ongoing
constitutional convention authorized to
alter and amend the real Constitution
which essentially exists only in their
opinions and nowhere else whereas the
rest of us sit at their feet to learn
what the Constitution may yet become now
if this seems somehow not quite right to
you you're making progress today this
understanding of judicial supremacy is
virtual dogma in America's law schools
it was succinctly expressed by columnist
Ruth Marcus in the Washington Post on
Sunday haven't those presidential
candidates heard of Marbury vs. Madison
bang end of story
but interestingly enough this was not
the court's own view of its power until
fairly recently the first time the court
said anything quite like that off the
cuff and off the court a remark of
Hughes was in 1958 in a case called
Cooper versus Aaron there the courts
logic went like this the Constitution is
the supreme law of the land higher than
any laws that may country to contradict
it well that you can look up in article
six secondly ever since mark
versus Madison the court has understood
that the court said now the federal
judiciary is supreme in the exposition
of the law of the Constitution and so it
follows conclusion that the decisions of
the Supreme Court are themselves the
supreme law of the land and must be
followed by oath bound public officials
as equivalent for the Constitution
itself I promise you there any
philosophy professors who teach logic in
here they can confirm this the logic is
impeccable and so the conclusion follows
if the premises are true and the first
one is indisputable the Constitution is
the supreme law of the land
certainly it says it as much but the
second premise to say the least is
dubious
even if Marbury vs. Madison stood for a
judicial supremacy of authoritative
depth and the best reading of it I
believe is that it does not it is simply
not true that the country has believed
for the last now two hundred and twelve
years that whatever the court says about
the Constitution simply is the
Constitution now let me come back to
Roberts and his obergefell denunciation
of an extravagant conception of judicial
supremacy which of our three possible
meanings did he mean to denounce not the
third all the justices of the current
Supreme Court so far as I can tell
believe what their predecessors said in
Cooper about their own rulings being the
supreme law of the land
that's simply part of the judicial
mindset today the judicial supremacy of
authoritative death I think as well it's
it's doubtful that Roberts meant to
denounce the second meaning the judicial
supremacy of textual breadth for all
practical purposes all the justices
today are on board with enforcing
anything in the Constitution whatever's
in it is fair game for judicial
interpretation now I think he intends
only
denounce the first meaning I gave what I
called the judicial supremacy of
imperial power
he's perturbed rightly by the
transparently despotic move of the
majority in obergefell he's perturbed
perhaps particularly by the explicitly
living Constitution approach that
Justice Kennedy takes for the majority
as when Kennedy writes this the
generations that wrote and ratified the
Bill of Rights in the 14th amendment did
not presume to know the extent of
freedom in all its dimensions and so
they entrusted to future generations a
charter protecting the right of all
persons to enjoy Liberty as we learn its
meaning when new insight reveals discord
between the Constitution's central
protections and a received legal
structure a claim to Liberty must be
addressed this is an astonishing
inversion of the truth about the
Constitution it is true that our
ancestors who wrote and ratified it did
not imagine their work captured the
meaning of a free society in all its
dimensions
yeah Justice Kennedy takes that
commonplace truism combines it with
another blandly true observation that
future generations can come to new
insight about such things and then like
a fellow on a street corner in Manhattan
plays a shell game with the reader who
belatedly realizes that he means future
generations of judges are free to change
the meaning of the Constitution without
bothering with that democratic but
difficult amending process this is what
has Roberts exercised it's one thing to
say that judicial interpretation of the
actual Constitution carries an
obligation for others to obey it's
plausible I think for Roberts that all
issues of constitutional meaning are fit
matter for judges to decide but a made
up Constitution evolving from year to
year according to the new insight of any
five out of a set of nine unelected
judges that Constitution must be
considered binding on everyone else I
just can't
I've been suggesting and I want to go
further in this in this line and
suggesting that neither Chief Justice
Roberts nor any of his colleagues has
plumbed the true extent of the problem
of judicial supremacy if one accepts
what I call the second and third
meanings textual bread and authoritative
depth if everything that justices say
about anything in the Constitution is
simply to be obeyed as the law of the
land by everyone else then the judicial
supremacy of imperial power is virtually
guaranteed to arrive as well sooner or
later they're human beings
it'll happen indeed one might begin just
by accepting the third meaning
authoritative depth whatever the
Constitution whatever the court said is
about the Constitution is the
Constitution for all others with legal
authority and responsibility except only
that and I think sooner or later you
will find the judiciary's ambitions
expand to embrace both the textual
breadth and the imperial power so even
the dissenting justices in obergefell
this is sobering to think about they
seem unaware of how much they too are
part of the problem each of the four
dissenters in fact says in his own way
sometimes more than once each of them
the majority has put an end to the
debate over same-sex marriage which is
as much as to suggest it what the five
and the majority have said simply now is
the Constitution is the effective law of
the land Justice Alito
says well today's decision shows that
decades of attempts to restrain this
courts abuse of its authority have
failed now I don't know whom he has in
mind as the party's responsible for
those failed defense does he mean other
political actors citizens working
through other institutions have
attempted for decades to restrain the
court there's little little evidence of
that in recent history does he instead
mean I think he means merely that among
the justices themselves such attempts
have been made by means of persuasion
across the chambers in the course of
deciding cases it was said long ago by
another justice of the court Harlan
Fiske stone in 1936 he went on to be
chief justice as well that the only
check upon our own exercise of power is
our own sense of self-restraint
but if that's right that would mean that
alone among the institutions of American
government the Supreme Court wields
checks and balances in the separation of
powers while itself being subject to no
checks at all this amounts to circling
back to our problem of judicial
supremacy in the fullest most
extravagant sense of all three meanings
all right I said earlier that the four
justices in dissent have called on their
fellow citizens to risk resist but if
they like their fellow justices in the
majority and typical of their kind
accept the dogma of judicial supremacy
what possible form can such resistance
take here we have to start
transcend their categories from inside
the bubble created by the dogma of
judicial supremacy only to conventional
responses seem possible
one is to amend the Constitution this
has been done on a few occasions but
it's a Herculean undertaking the lack of
progress on a human life amendment since
Roe is a sobering reminder of the
difficulty
moreover the route of amending the
Constitution is not really a challenge
to judicial supremacy but can even be
seen as a concession to it an admission
that because we cannot rest the
Constitution we already have from the
control of the courts all that's left
for us to do is to change the future
Constitution and cross our fingers and
hope that they won't abuse that to the
other conventional response is simply to
promised to appoint better justices in
future we've heard this from current
candidates for the presidency I'll
appoint justices we'll get the
Constitution right and not abuse their
authority now this would be an
altogether good thing I have justices
that would never dream of doing what was
done in obergefell and better still to
have justices willing to overturn that
unconstitutional ruling when presented
with an opportunity ah but how present
them with the opportunity are their
active steps that might be taken now or
in the near future to challenge
supremacy itself and its latest unholy
fruits I think there are first of all it
will take more than the personal courage
of county clerks like Kim Davis of Rowan
County Kentucky it will take determined
leadership by a presidential
administration and members of Congress
these are the only rivals in the same
weight class as the Supreme Court second
it will take rhetorical leadership
princeton political scientist Keith
Whittington and a 2007 book titled the
political foundations of judicial
supremacy notes that judicial supremacy
which cannot be inferred Whittington
understands from the Constitution in
some uncontroversial way has in fact
been constructed over the course of our
history not only by the justices of the
court but by presidents and members of
Congress who have found it politically
advantageous to hand over ownership of
all constitutional issues to the judges
but at various times this myth
Whittington's word has been called into
question by strong presidents such as
Jefferson Jackson Lincoln to a lesser
extent FDR and Reagan but Abraham
Lincoln is our true model here
Lincoln resolutely opposed any
acceptance of the Dred Scott decision
from the moment of its announcement
right into his presidency he said the
decision has to be accepted as governing
the actual parties to the case but not
take as a rule for the decision of other
public officials charged with upholding
the Constitution as they understood and
so his administration issued patents and
passports to free black citizens
indicating their disagreement with that
citizenship question in Dred Scott and
Lincoln signed an act of Congress in
1862 prohibiting slavery in all the
territories in direct defiance of that
element of Dred Scott just as important
he provided rhetorical leadership
throughout here he is in his first
inaugural address dr. Spaulding
partially quoted this the candid citizen
must confess that if the policy of the
government upon vital questions
affecting the whole people is to be
irrevocably fixed by decisions of the
Supreme Court the instant they are made
in ordinary litigation between parties
and personal actions the people will
have ceased to be their own rulers
having to that extent
practically resigned their government
into the hands of that eminent tribunal
Lincoln identified the stakes are we our
own rulers or have we resigned our
government as to the most vital
questions affecting us all into the
hands of a tribunal of nine lawyers any
five of whom have authority to
governance some respects we have it
tougher than Lincoln in his day the
dogma of judicial supremacy was not so
universally embraced as today it was a
full century after Dred Scott before the
Court itself announced the dogma as its
own understanding in Cooper what changed
in the meantime
and is there anything we can do about
the grip of the dogma on the American
mind one interesting historical
development I want to talk about quickly
and provide something practical for us
to grab hold of change
change was made in the way the court
conducts its business exactly 90 years
ago this year this was the Judiciary Act
of 1925 an act of Congress known at the
time as the judges bill because members
of Congress members of the Supreme Court
actually drafted the legislation that
proceeded through the Congress the 1925
Act revolutionized the life of the
Supreme Court and contributed greatly to
its enlarged and exalted role in the
life of the nation briefly the story
goes like this by the beginning of the
20th century the docket of the court had
become so crowded with cases but the
justices were required to hear hundreds
of cases each year and many were held
over undecided to succeeding years of
the docket in the mid nineteen teens the
court was disposing of upwards of four
hundred five hundred even six hundred
cases a year actually disposing them not
counting the ones held over why so much
work because at the time the laws the
acts of Congress governing the
jurisdiction of the federal courts gave
too many litigants a right to take a
mandatory appeal to the Supreme Court
often in cases of no particular
importance when former President Taft
became Chief Justice in 1921 he made it
his mission to get the docket under
control thus the judges bill was of
paramount importance to Taft what that
bill did was bring an end to whole great
categories of Appeals that the court had
been obliged to consider and instituted
or broadened the modern modern writ of
certiorari system from then on Supreme
Court review of what lower federal
courts and state supreme courts decided
was increasingly discretionary the cases
could be taken by the justices for
review or they could be left alone as
the leading historians of the bill Felix
Frankfurter later a Supreme Court
justice and James Landis also have
harvard law at the time as they put it
after 1925 the supreme
would be quote the arbiter of legal
issues of national significance and the
court itself would be in charge of
saying what those were this in itself
was a watershed moment in the growth of
judicial supremacy the court did get
control of its docket in the 1931 term
for instance they decided 262 cases
sounds like a lot today but it was quite
a reduction over time the courts control
of this docket was made more and more
discretionary the most recent
legislation of any significance here was
a bill in 1988 that eliminated almost
all remaining mandatory appeals the late
Chief Justice Rehnquist persuaded his
colleagues that in screening for grants
of certiorari they should be more
stringent and reduced their workload
it's never of course hard to persuade
people to reduce their workload the last
term in which Warren Berger was chief
justice the court heard and decided 171
cases Rehnquist became chief then and by
1990 it 134 by the October 2000 term
just 88 cases including the two Bush
versus Gore cases that came up
unexpectedly Chief Justice Roberts who
had clerked for Rehnquist when he was an
Associate Justice followed suit
persuaded his colleagues to reduce the
docket still further the justices
decided 85 cases in the 2010 term 79 and
the 2012 term and as I said at the
outset just 76 included the Supreme
Court today hears fewer cases than at
any time in the last century and a half
undeniably and now here's only important
cases that's assuredly the justices own
view of the matter and the court has
maximized its time to consider each of
these relatively few cases and to write
lengthy opinions when deciding them but
do the justices hear all the truly
important cases they should last fall
about a year ago this time the court
declined to review decisions from the
4th 7th 9th and 10th circuits which have
collected
struck down the marriage laws of more
than 20 states only when the sixth
circuit caused a split among them in
November upholding the laws of its four
states only then did the court feel
obliged to take up the issue and then
Justice Kennedy had the temerity to
suggest in obergefell that lower court
rulings he had done much to encourage
and which he and his colleagues would
not lift a finger to review constituted
a trend in favor of same-sex mayor and
the courts had the court taken the cases
it declined a year ago it's quite
possible more than possible that the
same result in obergefell would have
been reached a few months sooner
nonetheless it should Apollo's that the
justices were by and large content to
have circuit judges revolutionize the
law of marriage in state after state as
long as the justices could get away with
saying nothing I want to suggest that
the 1925 Judiciary Act and its successor
acts that made the courts docket
discretionary I've turned out to be
extremely problematic features of our
legal system the wholly discretionary
control of the courts docket bites
justices has enabled them to impose
their will on the country with a minimum
of effort relying on lower courts to do
much of the dirty work
one feature preserved from earlier days
in the 1925 Act but which is now gone
and subsequent reforms could be
fruitfully revived the original judges
bill preserved a state's right of appeal
with mandatory review by the Supreme
Court when a state law was declared
contrary to the Federal Constitution by
a federal appeals court that should be
restored with no power of summary
dismissal or affirmance the justices
should be required to place cases on the
docket to receive briefs from the
parties and from friends of the court to
hear oral argument and to publish the
reasons for their decisions in signed
opinions moreover to be still more
missed
this while such cases are pending the
adverse judgments of lower federal
courts that held state law as
unconstitutional could be automatically
stayed in any class of cases that
Congress chooses to identify so that the
laws continue enforce unless and until
the Supreme Court affirms the adverse
judgment after full consideration still
more mischief could be achieved by
making the justices consider each case
from each state individually with
consolidation of similar cases for joint
argument and decision ruled out of order
all of these suggestions are squarely
within the power of Congress to enact
plenary authority over the lower courts
and capacious regulatory authority over
the appeals court of the appellate
process of the Supreme Court decision
made if these strictures had been in
place what would have been the result in
our recent string of high-handed
marriage rulings first of all none of
the federal court judgments against
state marriage laws would have gone into
effect until such time as the Supreme
Court rendered a final judgment fully 25
or more cases each perhaps to be
considered separately could have landed
almost simultaneously on the courts
docket none of the state's marriage laws
would have ceased to operate until each
state's case was heard and decided by
the highest court in the land and no
state would have had its opportunity to
be heard in that court foreclosed by the
justices decision in the case of any
other state
there is no question
Supreme Court could hear twice or even
three times as many fully argued cases
as it hears in a typical year today the
generation ago it heard more than twice
as many what I'm suggesting though is
not mere mischief and busy work for the
Supreme Court reform a jurisdiction and
judicial process I've just sketched
could even be enacted today and it would
effectively restore the marriage laws of
any state not explicitly governed by the
order in obergefell which affects only
the four states of the Sixth Circuit it
would require public officials in the
other states to be courageous enough to
act on their oath to the Constitution
without confusing it with an oath to
follow the Supreme Court's latest
pronouncements on the Constitution it
might take fresh acts of state
legislatures to restart the debate but
with the help of a determined Congress
and president who has the courage to
lead on this issue the debate over the
meaning of marriage could be reignited
are you sure about it we would say to
the justices decide this case decide it
again say it again say it over and over
Berg FL would then become not the end of
the debate that the dissenting justices
lamented but on another chapter in an
ongoing struggle to recapture the law
from the Supreme Court ah wouldn't the
court just double down on obergefell
repeatedly striking down one marriage
law after another wouldn't it better to
be better as some have suggested to
withdraw the jurisdiction of the court
from cases like this that's an option
that might have once made sense a year
or two or five ago but obergefell is in
the past the thing to do now is to
create opportunities for the court to
revisit the issue squarely in future
cases that it cannot avoid and to count
on time and the political and electoral
process to create opportunities for the
president and the Senate to fill
vacancies on the court with justices who
get it
justices who understand that the country
will not tolerate a rogue Supreme Court
intoxicated by the myth of its
supremacy it's not the judges
Constitution that's a falsehood that has
been increasingly fashionable since the
judges Bill of 1925 it's the people's
Constitution and with intelligent
creative leadership using the tools the
Constitution already makes available
no amendment necessary we can have it
back the dissenting justices themselves
have issued the call for resistance and
no doubt would welcome the opportunity
at a fifth vote to their number and
overturn the travesty of obergefell
let's not fail them or our posterity
thank you
lawyers love that passage in Tocqueville
that's right
I mean we we are we are a nation founded
on on the idea of the rule of law as
John Adams does Massachusetts
Constitution of 1780 and not of men that
the trouble now of course is that the
the gravest threat to the rule of law
comes with from those black-robed
priests of the law we call justices of
the Supreme Court Tocqueville was right
about many things but his his
observations on the Supreme Court in my
opinion left a lot to be desired the
very first article I ever published as a
scholar took him to task for advocating
a view of the Supreme Court as a set of
statesmen who said about you know
seeking the public good through the
shaping of the law
no it's statesmanship is for the
political branches the the law that the
formal technicalities of the law are for
or for judges and lawyers it's all so
I'm thinkin fortunately the case and
here I'll send like a critic of the
founding fathers that they they seem to
have provided us in retrospect with
insufficient checks on the Supreme Court
it's clear that judicial review though
not judicial supremacy was contemplated
by the framers of the Constitution but
some of the checks that they had in mind
including impeachment which Hamilton
mentions in Federalist 81 is available
for run amok judges they turned out not
to be as as useful as perhaps the
framers thought they were only one
justices and one justice has been
impeached in our history he was I would
say probably rightly acquitted but it
was a close case Samuel chase Jefferson
was right one of a surprisingly small
number of times about the Constitution
this time when when he's when he said
that after the chase acquittal
I'm Pietschmann was just a scarecrow so
so it I mean it so it turns out that
that that a prediction that seemed to be
false for at least 3/4 of a century
Brutus's prediction that
the Supreme Court would assume imperial
dimensions it came to be true in the
20th century now we have to rethink
where as Lincoln said you know our as
our cases new we have to think anew and
act anew so we have to take what the
Constitution makes available to us and
think anew about the threat to the rule
of law that judges are one one way we
can begin to do it is to get in the
habit of referring to Supreme Court
rulings that get the Constitution wrong
as unconstitutional rulings you ever
noticed that we we easily and readily
say that an act of Congress or an active
state legislature is unconstitutional
that high-handed imperial president has
done something unconstitutional but we
almost never say as we should that a
Supreme Court ruling is unconstitutional
we should I would be thing one mr.
Stewart Reuter there's another way to
amend the Constitution that would bypass
our dysfunctional Congress yes that is
the convention of states is that an
article 5 it is item could you talk
about that please sure the Constitution
provides two ways to propose amendments
and two ways to ratify them we've only
ever proposed amendments the first by
the first method by the vote of
two-thirds of each house of Congress but
you can mandate that Congress call a
convention to propose amendments when
two-thirds of the states have called
upon Congress to do so I'm not sure
where we are in recent calls by states
how close we are to the two-thirds
margin but it appears on the face of
things to be obligatory for the Congress
to call such a convention once that
threshold of two-thirds of the states
has met that convention can of course in
principle I think propose anything there
are people who argue about whether you
can confine such a convention to the
kinds of proposed
that gave life to the movement to call
it in the first place I rather think you
you can't I mean look at Philadelphia
1787 it kind of went beyond their brief
there too and did much more than amend
the Articles of Confederation this is
reason perhaps to worry about you know a
so-called runaway convention but
whichever way you get amendments
proposed by Congress or by such a
convention then of course they're sent
out to the states for ratification
either by three-fourths of the states
acting in their legislatures or by
three-fourths of the states acting in
special conventions convened just for
that purpose that was only done once to
repeal prohibition that's the only
amendment we ever did ratified that way
but yeah I I'm you know I'm actually
opposed to most of the amendments we
already have so some some I'm not wild
about proposing constitutional
amendments to deal with the problems in
the framers constitution of 1787 now
someone's going to want to know which
amendments I would get rid of can misuki
wait for the mic good to see you again
oh yeah yeah
a tough one you know it looks to me like
judge Bunning is simply carrying out the
remorseless logic of Justice Kennedy's
obergefell ruling and it's it's the
Kennedy majority and not judge Bunning
who's the problem I mean I yeah for
encouragement of the others as they say
yeah I suppose so
certainly I think it's worth having some
congressional hearings on the whole
universe of problems here Kim Davis's
case is is a is a difficult one I think
that that as a public official she's
giving you know inspiring and courageous
witness to the truth about marriage and
the truth about religious conscience and
yet someone in Rowan County is obliged
as a matter of law now in a state that
is governed by obergefell
Kentucky being in the sixth circuit
someone in the county seemingly has to
issue the marriage licenses
so I'm sympathetic to her but also to
Judge Bunning mr. ting respects
yeah it's that that's a that's a tough
question yeah it's going to take some
creativity the the one of the I actually
left out a short portion of my prepared
lecture to save time but one of the
difficulties here is that in Dred Scott
as Lincoln said in his first inaugural
address it was a it was a personal
action that is it was a it was a lawsuit
between private parties putative
putative slave and putative slave owner
who were suing one you know they were in
a lawsuit struggling over the slaves
claim of freedom and federal law was
implicated in the case that is part of
the slaves case rested upon grounds in
the court struck down the Missouri
Compromise but as Lincoln said we can
consider the cases impact as confined to
those parties of the case and we don't
have to consider it as governing other
parties here's the difference today the
parties in obergefell include public
officials of four states who are
effectively enjoined to grant same-sex
marriage licenses and unlike say the
situation with Roe vs. Wade in which
legislators were free to probe at the
edges for the last 42 years of the
abortion license with new regulations or
limits on partial-birth abortion that
sort of thing obergefell
effectively imposes an affirmative
obligation on those public officials
this is what Judge Bunning has done to
Kim Davis to grant these marriage
licenses
actually in its in it's sort of wicked
simplicity and even tougher nut to crack
then than the one that Lincoln faced
with Dred Scott but we have to think it
through